[Applaudissements]
mercredi soir mais sa part de marché le
soin oui c'est vrai bien fait toutefois
potable ou plus envie de faire la fête
un peu plus tard dans la semaine
jusqu'au bout dans un peu ouais ça se
tente et c'est la lecture baby même type
pas de danse et magie des mots toi quand
même depuis 24 heures je sais parler de
moi quand une personne qui a décidé de
me rendre hommage en foire ont
littéralement à bus tam on y va
crescendo
[Applaudissements]
alors un must très raté est très moche
oui c'est vrai merci parce que mes nerfs
solides sport elle connaît la vie elle
connaît la beauté elle connaît la
chemise en jean
ça va très vite et c'est un amour ça on
adore vraiment elle est là elle a tout
fait mais oui à notre invitation donc
merci à vous voilà et c'est vrai que ça
fait plaisir de voir de belles blondes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]